[Music]
that's right I saw you at a restaurant I
was with my wife and I believe you were
with a you were on a date and I saw you
at a table I went over there and you
kind of gave me the get out of here
sign my Moho no Joe
[Applause]
I'm not sure what that means I know what
that means never do that actually the
guy was so excited to meet you and it
was a good day it was a good day you
know so I so you're out there you're
dating I've someone told me that you're
right you're kind of a cheap date is
that true
I love chains and you know this bount
way we've talked about I love olive
garden and chilies and Applebee's
I love Outback Steakhouse the bloomin
onion is not to be believed are you
getting money for this yeah my all-time
favorite is Sonic have y'all heard of it
yeah kings and queens I actually don't
know if they're kings and queens but
they they are they put the mmm on tater
tots and now they have a new I'm sweet
you're getting money for this I wish
they would call me I would do their ads
but the problem with Sonic is you're
gonna hear from them by the way I think
you're the first celebrity I've ever
heard go anywhere and say I gotta talk
about Sonic I love the selections they
have cranberry if you want to be more
healthy grave and but you know they've
never ever their commercials are in a
car and if they ask me to do their
commercials I mean oh you have to eat
the food in a car oh yeah they would
know is you know good oh they have
cheese taters and loaded
I'm a believer sonic go to yours today
so they're they don't have him in LA
they show the commercials but it's just
why would they show the commercials here
if they don't have that's what I want to
know it's just mocking us oh yeah
Bakersfield wherever that is oh I
actually like Bakersfield because they
have Applebee's I know this about you I
like any restaurant where you use a tray
I really do I think so now about
scissors I love putting food on a tray
and then going in city I love sizzler
yeah I'm gonna stop you why what's wrong
with slide time on vacation and West
Virginia we were driving along and with
my dad to sizzler we pulled in I kid you
not now I'm sure Sizzlers all good
except this one sizzler we had chicken
fried steak he bit into it and guess
what he bit into what a tooth wait when
chef de sister advertised on this hey
Jer you first of all that was probably
his own tooth he got him now yeah
[Laughter]
this is simpler I'm with sizzler on this
one
I'm one sister they're trained when that
happens to go we have a winner okay well
I'm gonna distance myself from the
lawsuit you brought up just a second ago
your height
I do forget because the most times I see
you I wanna show you the rest what
you're sitting down and then just now I
greet you and we are quite a pair okay
if we had a child that would be
normal-sized that's the sexiest thing
[Applause]
[Music]
anyone's anity look at this right here
let's go look at that look at that tail
come here sure alright look at that I'm
just
we both have the same problem which is
what you're all leg and so my I have no
torso yes that's my thing - I have Mike
that's where my waist is when I walk
around and while on the circus legs
oh my god
[Applause]
the hell's going on
we talked about Sonic here a slander to
restaurant chain and then rhymes with
the wiggler no one wants to hear that
about sizzler rhymes with Whistler
good luck planning a toot
[Laughter]